[Music]
you may think the creators over at
nickelodeon are your friends
but they have been pulling the wool over
your eyes for years
stay tuned for the secret when character
in hey arnold was always
hiding want more great content be sure
to check out 10
adult jokes you never noticed in your
favorite nickelodeon cartoons on the
gamer
now on to 10 inappropriate things
nickelodeon snuck by
without you knowing weird ad
nickelodeon is supposed to be a nice
kid-friendly channel
parents should always be able to turn on
nickelodeon leave their kids in a room
and be completely sure that they won't
be seeing
anything that they shouldn't
unfortunately that is not actually the
case
nickelodeon loves to sneak in weird
jokes and references that are just
too adult for children in fact most
children don't even notice them
which is why we have gone through some
of our favorite shows to point them out
the first on the list is hey arnold
in the scene pictured arnold and his
friends gerald
are both sitting down outside while
grandpa phil
stands over them that's all well and
good but do you see the sign behind them
it says try my sausage this could have
been a completely innocent
sign and someone could have really had
some sausage for cell
but from the surprise look on their
faces and how unprofessionally the sign
is written we are led to think otherwise
if this is the case then this is super
gross
why would nickelodeon put such a
suggestive ad in a kid's television show
they probably didn't think kids would
pick up on it but surely parents would
inappropriate videos it's always a
little weird when our favorite tv
characters watch tv inside their shows
but for the most part it's pretty
harmless except when it comes to
nickelodeon
for some reason nickelodeon likes to
have the characters in its shows
watch inappropriate things for instance
there is one episode of spongebob
squarepants where he is sitting
and watching television to us it looks
like he is just watching a video of sea
life but then
as soon as gary comes in the room he
flips the channel
he becomes super embarrassed and says
that he was looking for another channel
why would he do that unless he was
watching something super dirty but
that isn't the only show that has an
example of this
take rugrats for instance while tommy's
grandpa is watching the kids
he pulls out a video called lonely space
vixens
he even tells the kids that he's not
going to watch the movie until they go
to bed
gross right why is nickelodeon so
obsessed with having the characters in
our favorite shows have such a nasty
hobby
these are kids shows there is no reason
to include little parts like this in the
cartoons
but as long as people keep letting these
scenes go by unchecked
nick will keep putting them in there
pants debacle
rarely do we ever get to see our
favorite cartoons grown up
usually they remain frozen at whatever
age they were when the show first aired
because of this we don't see a lot of
awkward things that come along with
growing up and getting older
like puberty but that is not the case
with rugrats
after the show had been off the air for
a while the creators of the show decided
to create
rugrats all grown up when the show was
announced rugrats fans everywhere jumped
for joy
they were finally going to get to see
how all of their favorite characters
turned out
but it turned out that the show was
actually a little too adult at times
just look at this picture
it shows susie literally looking into
this guy's pants
and what's even weirder about it is the
fact that no one seems to care
they're just walking about like nothing
weird is happening
but this kid has his pants open how is
no one saying anything
how is susie not repulsed these are
questions that we need
answers to nickelodeon producers if
you're watching this
let us know what you were thinking with
this scene woodstock
usually in cartoons there aren't many
references to illegal behavior
you probably think that should go
without saying right but for some reason
it doesn't
nickelodeon loves to put strange little
references to illegal activities
throughout the show
just take this one for example arnold
from hey arnold is talking to his
grandfather grandpa phil
he tells grandfather phil that he
shouldn't worry because he's still got
plenty of brain cells left grandpa phil
then tells arnold that he doesn't have
as many brain cells as he once had
since he went to woodstock if you don't
know what woodstock is it was a music
festival that took place in 1969.
it's widely known for the illegal
smoking activities that went on there
by saying this grandpa phil is basically
saying that he partook in a lot of these
activities
which is why he no longer has any brain
cells did you catch that joke when you
watched it as a kid
probably not most kids have no idea what
woodstock is or what went on there
so clearly that joke was for the parents
but we really wonder if parents actually
enjoy these inappropriate jokes
being in their children's television
shows we don't think we would like it
very much
would you no vacancy there are some
shows that you just expect inappropriate
things to be a part of
rocco's modern life was one of those
shows from the beginning to the end of
each episode the show
is chock full of things that aren't
suitable for kids if you didn't notice
any of these things then you probably
weren't watching close enough
in one episode there was even a hotel
called the no-tell motel
doesn't that just sound creepy why would
you need a motel that doesn't tell
what are people doing in there that
needs to be kept a secret it also says
that the rooms come complete with
wawa beds we're guessing that means
water beds
why do these rooms need water beds
everything about this hotel seems super
skeevy it also says that they have
hourly rates available
most times when a hotel rinse by the
hour people are not intending on
sleeping there if you catch our drift
we know this show is known for how
inappropriate it is
but this one really took the cake there
is a fine line between being funny and
just going way too far
we think this joke might have been on
the bad side of the lines
inappropriate eating nickelodeon doesn't
just have cartoons
nope there are some scripted shows on
the channel as well so we can't leave
them out
you might think the scripted shows would
be less likely to have inappropriate
material but that's not the case at all
some of the scripted shows are super
inappropriate we are talking about you
icarly icarly may have seemed innocent
enough but if you pay attention you can
catch some weird sexual undertones in
this show
for instance we know that sam loves to
eat she eats in almost every episode of
the show
but sometimes when she eats it's in such
a sexual manner that we can't help but
be creeped out
one time that this went too far was when
sam sucks some cream
out of some pink fat cakes while she did
this freddy and spencer watched her with
their mouths hanging open
how much more suggestive could the show
be well the answer is actually a lot
more suggestive
if you go back and look at any of the
things that sam eats
there is usually a sexual undertone
behind it we aren't sure why nick
decided to go this route when dealing
with sam but
we wish they hadn't bleak jokes as you
have seen from the rest of this video
nickelodeon is no stranger to
inappropriate jokes but sometimes the
jokes are taken too far and go from
funny to downright sad
take this to an example for instance in
one scene in rugrats grandpa boris gets
tired of watching stu's videos
so what does he do he called dr
kevorkian
if you don't know anything about dr
kevorkian he was a doctor that strongly
endorsed assisted suicide so by grandpa
boris calling the doctor
it pretty much alluded to the fact that
he would rather pass away than watch any
more of stu's videos
we get joking around but joking about
losing your life is
serious we also don't think that many
kids probably understood the dr
kevorkian reference
at least we hope they didn't so why
include it in the scene
do the creators of the shows just get so
bored that they have to include little
jokes for themselves to catch
if that's the case then they should
really just find some other way to keep
the show fun
because including jokes about assisted
suicide is definitely
not the way to go kids shouldn't have to
worry about being exposed to jokes like
that when they watch
television drinking problems many
cartoons portray
families that are pretty perfect there
are usually two parents who love and
care for their kids
very well but in hey arnold one family
had a not so hidden secret issue
do you know what we were talking about
helga's mom was an alcoholic
yes she was if you go back and watch
certain episodes you can definitely tell
she was always slurring her words you
might just think that this was because
she was tired
but think about it hard she was always
making her special
smoothies too she even had to do
community service at one point this
could have been because she got a dui
to top it all off she was always falling
asleep everywhere
doesn't that sound like the behavior of
a drunk we could see
nick making helga's mama drunk so that
they could teach some valuable life
lesson on the show
but they didn't use it for that reason
in fact they never really acknowledged
it on the show
so it seemed that they just made her an
alcoholic for no reason
it served no purpose it didn't add
anything to the story line and there
were no lessons learned from the story
or anything
weird hookups why are cartoons so full
of adult moments these days
seriously can't we have anything that is
pure anymore
since we were talking about hey arnold
let's go ahead with another example of
how the show is seriously
messed up at times in one scene arnold
and gerald are going on a road trip with
gerald's dad
and arnold's grandpa while they are in
the car grandpa phil starts to go into
detail about a story that happened when
he was younger
he says that he was sleeping in a barn
when a young woman named monique
came and knocked on the barn door he
described what she was wearing as a
figure flattering dress
he was about to go into more detail
about what happened when gerald's dad
cut him off before the story got too
inappropriate thank goodness for
gerald's dad or else we would have
gotten
too many details about that story can
you imagine if he had gone through the
whole story
why would he think that his grandson and
grandson's best friend needed to know
about that story
and how much detail was he going to go
into we guess we will never know but
that's probably for the best
don't you think misunderstandings
misunderstandings can sometimes be
pretty comical
they are the focus of a lot of jokes on
many shows but some of the
misunderstandings on nickelodeon shows
are just
downright dirty for instance in a scene
in cat dog one character is telling
another that he needs to act classier
he says you're with classy people now so
show some class
at this the other character begins to
pull down his pants
obviously he got the word class mixed up
with a much dirtier word
but it just makes you think why would a
cartoon character think that they need
to show their butt in order to impress
classy people
that screams sexual harassment was there
sexual harassment going on in a
fictional workplace
we certainly hope not but the fact that
the character was so willing to drop his
pants
makes it seem like that that may have
been the case we get that it was a
misunderstanding but what a weird
conclusion to jump to we wonder why kids
who watch the show think about what
happened did they realize that the
character was literally about to show
his butt in order to impress his boss
we really hope that no kids picked up on
that and that's it for 10 inappropriate
things nickelodeon
snuck by without you knowing were you
surprised by any of the things on this
list
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching see you next time